at the top of the show we talked about a
Vice news article which accurately and
correctly outlines
how there is now an open season on the
trans Community as a result of the
shooter in the Nashville Tennessee
shooting of being a trans individual now
this of course ignores that if you look
at the last 5 000 mass shootings there
have been like three or four trans or
non-binary Shooters ignores all facts in
reality that a drag show where stories
are read to kids not necessarily by
trans people just by drag performers
has nothing to do with what took place
in Nashville Tennessee doesn't matter
it's now open season and one of the
primary perpetrators
here is radical repugnant and
reactionary Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green or Marjorie green
Taylor or Marjorie Trader green
depending on your preference she has now
been suspended from Twitter after a
warning about trans vengeance
Newsweek reports
representative Marjorie Taylor green
claimed that her Congressional Twitter
account has been suspended after sharing
unfounded information about a trans day
of Vengeance in the wake of the
Nashville school shooting
as you know the shooter ultimately
killed at least six people including
three young students and three adult
faculty members
police have yet to officially describe
disclose a probable motive they've
confirmed the shooter identified as
trans although it remains unclear in
which ways and to what degree it was the
case nevertheless several prominent
conservative figures like green have
attempted to link Hale's actions to
being trans insinuating with little
evidence that gender transition drugs or
surgeries were to blame in some manner
Green in particular tweeted about a
supposed event called the trans day of
Vengeance linking it to the Nashville
shooting and alleging a broader threat
of trans-terrorism later green claimed
her personal on her personal account
that her Congressional account was
suspended because of those tweets
the original tweet and subsequent ones
have been deleted but Newsweek was able
to view some of them
after three thousand retweets of this
tweet my account was suspended again why
is Twitter whitewashing the trans day of
Vengeance Elon Musk
a day after a murder of children by a
trans shooter people need to know about
the threat they face from antifa and
trans terrorism
in her own post on the matter Ella Irwin
who's the VP of trust and safety at
Twitter said the platform automatically
swept for tweets containing a poster for
the trans day of Vengeance and took him
down no matter who was sharing it or why
makes sense Marjorie Taylor green
shouldn't get special treatment on
Twitter because she's an elected
official
we had we had to automatically sweep our
platform and remove more than five
thousand tweets slash retweets of this
poster we do not support tweets that
incite violence irrespective of who
posts them Vengeance does not imply
peaceful protest organizing or support
for peaceful protests is okay
later responding to a claim from Irwin
that accounts were not receiving strikes
for sharing at Green shared a screenshot
of an explanation she purportedly
received and said this is a lie
um she posts saying that she's been
limited because of some of the things
she posted whatever
listen
seeing the right wing rush to spread
transphobia
and more generally the anti-lgbt
sentiment
since the shooting earlier this week
it's disturbing and it's depressing but
it's also horrifying of course Marjorie
Taylor green is a particularly
disgusting and abhorrent person I would
argue even by the standards of the
average of the Republican Party you've
got what I consider to be the more
honest actors in the Republican party
people like Willard Mitt Romney Adam
kinsinger Liz Cheney people with whom I
disagree on policy and who certainly
hold some views I find disgusting
including for example on abortion but
they are at least more honest actors in
the Republican party that would call
them on the better side of the
Republican party then you've kind of got
the middle the average of the crazies
and the people like Romney and Cheney
Etc
and then you have people like Marjorie
Taylor green
Matt Gates Lauren bobert Lauren bobert
all of you know all of these types of
folks Marjorie Taylor green even by the
average of the modern Republican party
is particularly disgusting and as always
is the case and I mentioned this earlier
and it Bears repeating again
it's always too soon to politicize
shootings
when it's the typical shooting and what
I mean by that is
white male
Born in the USA
under age 25.
then it's too soon to politicize and any
discussion of actually doing a damn
thing about what's going on is
inappropriate when we try to find actual
Solutions when we say hey you know what
had there been a waiting period and had
the person been unable to buy
high-capacity magazines because of their
age or all of the different things that
I talk about 10 different proposals then
this shooting either wouldn't have
happened or fewer people would have died
both of which would be better than what
we oh that David that's too soon how
dare you how dare you uh politicize a
tragedy before they've even buried their
dead well when we wait then nothing
happens
and the NRA does its thing and they do
their dog and pony show and nothing
happens well as we are seeing now they
don't actually care about politicizing
these tragedies too soon because
Marjorie Taylor green and Tucker Carlson
and the whole lot of them
immediately politicized it when it was
about clamping down on the trans
community and linking this to what they
call trans women in sports and drag
shows and CRT and all of this sort of
stuff as always they claim to care about
the deficit but they don't they only
care about the deficit when it's a
democrat in the White House they claim
to care about uh election Integrity
except when they try to steal an
election that they lost it's all
projection and similarly they care about
not politicizing mass shootings
except when it's convenient to
politicize a mass shooting the Trump
says at his rallies there has never been
a movement like this
and he's right but there has never been
a movement this depraved
and uh I am fearful of what comes next
let me know your thoughts and we will
follow up on this for sure